hi there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about how
language learning is
very much a subjective
activity and all of
you know of what that implies
um
and the reason this thought came to me
is
uh you know obviously we have this
coveted epidemic now and um
you know what affects your
ability to contract the disease and how
severely you will be affected by
the disease depends on a number of
factors many of which we don't yet know
and and as
the scientists learn more about the
covet they'll have a better idea of
different people's vulnerability and and
what kinds of situations are most
dangerous
they know a lot already some people who
have certain medical conditions or of a
certain age are more likely to be
you know adversely affected by covid and
yet there are surprises there are young
apparently very healthy people who are
very severely affected by covet
now language learning is different in
the case of covid there are certain
we don't know what all the factors are
but there are some objective factors
that we don't control
that will affect how we are you know uh
how badly we're impacted by cobit but
language learning is not like that you
know our ability to learn languages it
does vary from person to person
but
we also influence those things so it's
not a purely sort of objective factor i
am obese or i am of a certain age and
therefore i'm statistically more likely
to
contract a severe form of covet
in terms of language learning
i can
control
the sort of emotional
uh attitudinal part of language learning
is very very important
and unfortunately many of the studies
that are done
on what works in language learning and
i've been doing a bit of research they
have a term gll good language learners
and it all deals with
either techniques in the classroom that
the teacher can use
or techniques that learners supposedly
use like they're more inclined to guess
is
suggested as one
characteristic of good language learners
um i don't really guess i think i'm a
fairly good language learner
i try not to guess
um
ultimately
it's a matter of you know how motivated
are we they do these studies of
uh how long does it take to learn a
language how long does it take
uh
you know to learn different languages
and it's all based on a classroom
situation i remember some years ago
seeing a study done by uh in the united
states showing how
classroom hours affect
you know how quickly immigrants learn
english but of course there's so many
factors that have nothing to do with the
classroom uh is the particular immigrant
you know working in an environment where
there are other english speakers
does that person watch english-speaking
television programs uh
does that person react positively to
english-speaking television programs or
do they kind of not really like the
culture nothing wrong with not liking
any particular culture but obviously
those kinds of subjective things are
going to influence how easily they learn
the language
so
and i've had a number of discussions
recently interviews with people we talk
about what affects language learning and
it's not possible to like everything in
a in a new culture
but it should be possible to find some
things that we like
or people that we like or voices that we
like or subject matter that we like so
that we create as positive a subjective
environment as possible you can't just
tell people go and find friends in the
language if those people are not
positively attracted to the language
so
you know it once we recognize the
subjective nature of
language learning not only in terms of
initiative by the language learner but
also in terms of
emotionally how the learner reacts to
the language what the interests of the
learner are
it can also be a matter of confidence
obviously a person who has learned more
languages is more confident so that's a
subjective factor
i i don't think it's so much a matter of
the language learning techniques that
good language learners use i think it's
rather that the good language learners
allow themselves to get carried away
with a language find things interesting
in the language
and then in their desire to learn more
about the language and the culture they
will naturally find
certain techniques
there that that work they're more
willing to accept uncertainty because
they're so interested in what they're
reading or listening to or interested in
certain people so a lot of the sort of
techniques you know accepting
uncertainty
guessing or not guessing whatever
accepting the fact that you're going to
forget
and relearn
accepting the fact that you're going to
be embarrassed because you can't
remember things or you have to ask
someone to repeat things and all of
these sort of inhibiting factors
if we subjectively have an attitude that
says i'm interested i like it i like the
sound
then we sort of
are prepared to
fight our way through some of these
negative things so if the person
subjectively
doesn't really like being with speakers
of that language which is understandable
so a lot of these subjective things are
going to inhibit their success
so
whenever i see studies about what works
in language learning typically based on
the classroom experience
where i find that the classroom is
almost irrelevant to language learning
whether a learner is in a classroom or
not is the other
the things that the learner does outside
the classroom which are largely dictated
by the learner's attitude towards the
language or towards the process of
learning in other words subjective
factors
and
these subjective factors i think should
be studied in greater detail to see how
we can create more
subjective positive
attitudes towards a particular language
or towards the process of language
learning that rather than any techniques
of language learning or language
teaching i think have a much greater
influence so there you have it i look
forward to your comments
[Music]
you